>>> WYOMING HAS THE SMALLEST
POPULATION IN THE COUNTRY, YET
ITS CONGRESSIONAL PRIMARY RACE
TOMORROW IS HIGHLY ANTICIPATED.
THE COWBOY STATE HAS ONLY ONE
CONGRESSIONAL SEAT, AND RIGHT
NOW IT'S FILLED BY REPUBLICAN
LIZ CHENEY.
BUT IT IS AN UPHILL BATTLE FOR
HER TO KEEP THAT SEAT AFTER SHE
VOTED TO IMPEACH DONALD TRUMP
AND THEN BECAME THE VICE CHAIR
OF THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE.
TRUMP WON WYOMING WITH ALMOST
70% OF THE VOTE IN 2020.
AND AT THE MOMENT, CHENEY IS
RUNNING ALMOST 30 PERCENTAGE
POINTS BEHIND HER TRUMP-BACKED
OPPONENT HARRIET HAGEMAN.
CHENEY IS EVEN ASKING DEMOCRATS
TO SWITCH PARTIES TO VOTE FOR
HER.
I WANT TO GET PERSPECTIVE FROM
TWO WYOMING VOTERS, ONE WHO DID
SWITCH PARTIES JUST TO VOTE FOR
CHENEY, AND THE OTHER A
REPUBLICAN WHO PLANS TO VOTE
AGAINST LIZ CHENEY.
LET'S START WITH MYRNA.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
WHAT DON'T YOU LIKE ABOUT LIZ
CHENEY?
>> WELL, I THINK ONE THING THAT
STANDS OUT TO ME AT THIS POINT
IN TIME IS THAT, WHILE SHE HAS
BEEN A VERY CONSERVATIVE VOTE IN
THE LEGISLATURE, SHE JUST SEEMS
TO BE SWINGING A LITTLE BIT MORE
TOWARD THE LEFT.
BUT EVEN BEFORE THAT IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS, IT JUST DOES
NOT FEEL SHE REALLY REPRESENTS
THE STATE ANYMORE.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT, MYRNA,
BECAUSE WHEN YOU SAY SHE'S
SWINGING MORE TOWARDS THE LEFT,
I THINK SHE VOTED ON -- IN TERMS
OF THE ISSUES, SHE IS WHERE
DONALD TRUMP IS.
SHE VOTED WITH DONALD TRUMP I
THINK ON 93% OF THE TIME.
SHE'S CONSERVATIVE.
AND SO --
>> I GET THAT.
>> YEAH.
SO, WHAT -- IN TERMS OF -- WHY
AREN'T THOSE ISSUES OR HER
POSITIONS ON THOSE ISSUES AS
IMPORTANT TO YOU?
>> WELL, LIKE I SAY, THAT HAS
BEEN THE CASE.
BUT HERE RECENTLY -- I MEAN, YOU
TAKE, FOR EXAMPLE, THE GUN VOTE.
THAT IS NOT PRO-WYOMING.
SHE IS NOT REPRESENTING HER
CONSTITUENTS ANYMORE.
WHEN YOU START VOTING AGAINST
GUN S AND THE SECOND AMENDMENT,
THAT BECOMES AN ISSUE FOR A
LARGE NUMBER OF WYOMINGENS.
AND YOU LOOK AT THE CHIP BILL.
THAT'S A CORPORATE GIVE AWAY.
AND THAT'S NOT EXACTLY A
CONSERVATIVE VOTE AS WELL.
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THE
ROLE HE'S PLAYED IN
INVESTIGATING THE JANUARY 6th
INVESTIGATION?
>> I DON'T LIKE IT.
>> WHY NOT?
>> I FEEL LIKE -- WELL, I FEEL
LIKE SHE DID NOT EVEN BOTHER TO
STOP AT THE VERY INCEPTION OF
THIS.
HER BASIC TAKE ON IT WAS, I DO
NOT -- I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
FACTS ARE.
I'VE ALREADY MADE UP MY MIND.
AND SHE SAID SOMETHING VERY MUCH
TO THAT POINT.
SHE ALREADY MADE UP HER MIND
BEFORE SHE EVER WENT IN THAT HE
WAS GUILTY OF WHAT THEY SAY HE
DID.
>> BUT ARE YOU COMFORTABLE WITH
IT BEING INVESTIGATED?
>> INVESTIGATE AWAY.
JUST DON'T MAKE IT A SET-UP.
THINGS DO NEED TO BE
INVESTIGATED.
BUT THEY NEED TO BE INVESTIGATED
FAIRLY.
>> AND DO YOU THINK THAT JOE
BIDEN IS THE LEGITIMATE WINNER
OF THE ELECTION?
>> I THINK THERE WAS A LOT OF
STUFF, A LOT OF STATES THAT
REALLY PULLED A LOT OF THINGS
THAT WEREN'T REALLY LEGAL.
I THINK THERE WERE A LOT OF
THINGS BEHIND THE SCENES.
I DON'T KNOW FOR SURE, BUT I'M A
LITTLE DOUBTFUL MYSELF.
YES.
>> DOES IT CONSOLE YOU AT ALL
THAT THERE WERE 60 PLUS JUDGES,
SOME OF THEM TRUMP APPOINTED,
ALL OF WHOM LOOKED AT WHATEVER
EVIDENCE WAS PRESENTED TO THEM
AND THEY DECIDED THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE OF ANY SORT OF
SIGNIFICANT FRAUD THAT WOULD
HAVE SWUNG THE ELECTION TO
DONALD TRUMP AND THAT JOE BIDEN
WAS THE LEGITIMATE WINNER?
>> I'M NOT REALLY SURE WHAT TO
THINK ABOUT THAT.
THAT'S -- THAT'S KIND OF A HARD
ONE FOR ME TO LOOK AT.
I ALSO KNOW THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT I CONSIDER VERY TRUSTWORTHY
SOURCES HAVE LOOKED AT THE DATA
AND THEY'VE LOOKED AT -- THEY'RE
VERY GOOD AT STATISTICS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT.
AND THERE ARE JUST THINGS THAT
DON'T QUITE ADD UP.
>> SO, WHAT DO YOU THINK LIZ
CHENEY --
>> I'M NOT SURE THE JUDGES HAD
THE INFORMATION OR IF THEY
DIDN'T.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK LIZ
CHENEY'S FUTURE IS?
>> WELL, IT'S KIND OF HARD TO
SAY WHETHER SHE'LL WIN HERE.
IT IS POSSIBLE THAT SHE WILL.
THERE'S PLENTY OF CHENEY
SUPPORTERS OUT THERE.
THERE'S PLENTY OF CHENEY SIGNS.
BUT THERE'S PLENTY OF HAGEMAN
SIGNS TOO.
I HAVE A SUSPICION SHE'S GOT
SOMETHING ELSE ON HER PLATE.
AND I THINK WYOMING ALWAYS WAS A
STEPPINGSTONE.
I DON'T THINK IT WAS HER
FIRST -- IT WAS HER FIRST STEP,
BUT I DON'T THINK IT WAS HER
ULTIMATE GOAL.
>> MEANING PRESIDENT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT'S IN HER
MIND.
I -- IT WOULDN'T SURPRISE ME.
I MEAN, THAT'S BEEN RUMORED VERY
MUCH.
IT'S A POSSIBILITY.
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'LL HAPPEN
EVEN IF -- EVEN IF SHE RUNS, I
REALLY CAN'T SEE IT HAPPENING.
>> MYRNA BURGESS, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
WE APPRECIATE GETTING YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON ALL OF THIS.
>> YOU BET.
>> AND NOW I WANT TO TURN TO
PAT, WHO'S A REGISTERED DEMOCRAT
FOR 40 YEARS BUT SWITCHED
PARTIES SO SHE COULD VOTE FOR
LIZ CHENEY.
SO, PAT, THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
SO, YOU ARE A LIFE LONG
DEMOCRAT.
WHY ARE YOU VOTING FOR SOMEONE
AS CONSERVATIVE AS CONGRESSWOMAN
CHENEY?
>> WELL, IT ISN'T BECAUSE OF ANY
POLICIES THAT SHE HAS SUPPORTED.
BUT I THINK IT'S LITERALLY A
VOTE TO HELP SAVE THE REPUBLIC.
I SEE HER AS A PERSON OF COURAGE
AND INTEGRITY, WHO HAS TOLD THE
TRUTH THAT DONALD TRUMP LOST THE
ELECTION AND YET TRIED WITH LIES
AND MANIPULATION TO STAY IN
OFFICE ANYWAY.
>> PAT, ISN'T IT SO
INTERESTING -- I MEAN, JUST THE
WAY, YOU KNOW, YOU REPRESENT THE
DEMOCRAT HERE.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE JUST TALKED TO
MYRNA ABOUT THIS -- THAT YOU ARE
WILLING -- BOTH OF YOU ARE
WILLING TO OVERLOOK HER POSITION
ON THE ISSUES.
YOU -- YOU DON'T THINK THAT HER
POSITION ON THE ISSUES IS AS
IMPORTANT.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> THAT IS TRUE.
I THINK YOU CAN ALWAYS WRITE A
LETTER, TALK TO YOUR
REPRESENTATIVE'S OFFICE AND
ARGUE POLICY.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO HAVING A
FREE AND FAIR ELECTION, THAT IS
ESSENTIAL.
AND THAT HAS TO BE UPHELD.
I DON'T WANT WYOMING'S LONE
REPRESENTATIVE TO BE SOMEONE WHO
IS BEHOLDEN TO AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
DEMANDS ABSOLUTE LOYALTY NO
MATTER WHAT TRICKS HE'S UP TO.
AND I THINK THAT HARRIET HAGEMAN
KNOWS PERFECTLY WELL THAT THE
ELECTION WAS NOT STOLEN, THAT IT
WAS NOT FRAUDULENT.
BUT SHE SAYS WHAT TRUMP WANTS TO
HEAR AND THEREFORE GOT HIS
ENDORSEMENT.
I THINK THAT'S PURE AMBITION.
>> PAT, AS I'M SURE YOU KNOW,
DEMOCRATS ARE OUTNUMBERED IN
WYOMING.
AND AT THE MOMENT, THE POLL
NUMBERS ARE NOT LOOKING GOOD FOR
CONGRESSWOMAN CHENEY.
HOWEVER, ANYTHING'S POSSIBLE.
OF COURSE TOMORROW.
DO YOU THINK THAT SHE IS GOING
TO WIN?
>> I THINK THE CHANCES ARE VERY
SLIM BECAUSE HER PARTY HAS
OSTRACIZED HER.
AND MANY REPUBLICAN VOTERS WILL
LISTEN TO THE EXTREME LEADERSHIP
THAT IS IN CHARGE OF THE WYOMING
GOP AT THIS TIME.
THEY WILL FOLLOW THAT LEAD.
>> AND THEN WHAT DO YOU THINK IS
NEXT FOR HER?
WOULD YOU VOTE FOR HER FOR
PRESIDENT?
>> I DON'T DOUBT THAT VERY MUCH.
I DON'T THINK THAT I WOULD.
>> PAT --
>> I THINK SHE'S GOING AWAY
THOUGH.
I THINK WHATEVER HAPPENS
TOMORROW, THAT WE HAVE CERTAINLY
NOT SEEN THE LAST OF LIZ CHENEY.
SHE'S HIGHLY INTELLIGENT,
DRIVEN.
AND I THINK SHE IS COMMITTED TO
SERVING THE COUNTRY.
>> PAT, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
REALLY APPRECIATE GETTING YOUR
PERSPECTIVE AS WELL.